in this video we'll talk about
his tag protein purification
his tag protein purification is a method
by which proteins can be purified by a
single step affinity chromatography by
using immobilized metal ion
chromatography now in this case
the affinity is the key principle behind
separation
in this technique a ni ntm matrix is
used a nickel nta matrix is used
and the protein is tagged with
hexahistidine
and there is an interaction between
these matrix and this particular
histidine tag which is very specific and
there are non-covalent interactions like
coordinate bonds between these two
and that that is how the protein gets
attached with this matrix and it's easy
to separate
so where does the histac come from
actually we have to attach this his tag
with the protein
in order to do so we have to start with
an expression vector where we clone our
open reading frame
and
in the n-terminal or the c-terminal of
this particular protein one can attach a
hexa-histidine tag at the dna level
now once this particular vector is
introduced into the bacterial culture or
let's say mammalian cell which depends
on the type of expression vector we are
using
these expression vector would give rise
to the protein inside these cells
and ultimately these proteins would be
tagged with this hexahistidine
so what is the advantage of this kind of
tag
using this tag we we can understand
where is our protein of interest in a
mixture of other proteins so we can
separate them from a mixture of proteins
now like any column chromatography this
particular
chromatography has a simple workflow
so it starts with a equilibration step
then a binding step where our protein of
interest binds
then a wash and a illusion step
let us go through these steps
in a bit slowly so first step is
equilibration where we run our
equilibration buffer through the column
in this equilibration step the column
material gets soaked and equilibrated
for a particular ph
now the buffer that we have are using it
has to be compatible with the protein of
interest that we want to purify
factors to keep in mind while choosing
this buffer are ionic strength and ph
so factors such as ionic strains are
limited by protein stability so if we
change the ionic strength the protein
might get denatured and while we are
purifying the protein we don't want a
denatured protein right we want it in
its native state
next step is binding here we give the
protein
or the cell lysate
so in this step
there are multiple proteins which are
present in the lysate
but our protein is tagged so it is able
to bind to the matrix now protein
samples are generally dissolved in
specific buffers and loaded into the
columns proteins bind to the column via
several non-covalent interaction in this
case
the non-covalent interaction is
coordinate bonds
once protein have been immobilized in
the stationary phase then we have to use
wash buffer so the next step is washing
washing nco ensures that you don't have
any other non specific bound stuff in
the column all the non-specific untagged
proteins would be washed away in this
stage during the stage of washing all
the
all the weak bonds or non-covalent
interactions are broken down and only
the specific interactions are retained
now last step is illusion in this
illusion step we want to collect the
protein that is bound in the column
so
after all the non-specific interactions
are removed now we are using a
particular buffer which has a altered ph
and ionic strength which would loosen up
the binding between the matrix and the
protein of interest and then it would
come down into the
tube and we can collect that
so now we understand how we can use his
tag protein purification to purify our
protein of interest from a mixture of
protein
once we have purified our protein it is
important to
understand and cross check whether we
have uh whether this assay has worked or
not in order to do that we can run an
sds page and further do a western blot
against this particular protein
anyway let's talk about the benefits of
this purification this is compatible
with cell culture media and lysates
easy to use and quite sensitive and
specific
it is cheaper than many other
chromatographic technique such as gel
filtration chromatography or let's say
other kind of hplc techniques
anyway there are certain disadvantages
but that can be overcome the
disadvantage includes
this technique often requires
optimization to minimize non-specific
binding so many of the cases one has to
calibrate the ionic strength of the
equilibriation buffer or let's say the
binding buffer etc so little bit of
standardization is required but this
technique is really really specific and
important
you can get many flashcards and notes
regarding to these topics in my facebook
page you can follow me on instagram and
my instagram and facebook handle is
provided here links are provided in the
description
so in my instagram page there is daily
mcq you can participate in that and win
exciting prizes like these ones
anyway this is happening in my second
channel so subscribe that
you can support my channel using patreon
or beam upi app you can also click on
the super thanks option on the right
hand uh corner of the video
you can click on that and pay via net
banking paytm paypal or upi
all my social media links and handles
are provided in the description feel
free to connect see you in the next
video